the department of education says about
half of u.s adults ages 16 to 74 that's
about 130 million americans read below a
sixth grade level
a new book called reading for our lives
the literary action plan from birth to
six tackles the issue head on it says
our current approach to reading is
failing and ensuring literacy success
must begin at infancy first on cbs
mornings the books author maya payne
smart joins us right now good morning
how you doing good morning thanks so
much for having me of course now you
said that um you wish you had this guide
when your daughter was an infant why do
you think it's important to start so
early i think it's important to start so
early for a couple of reasons one so
that we can take advantage of this
amazing brain growth and development
that takes place for kids when they're
birth to three and also it makes you a
more knowledgeable parent as your child
approaches school age so you can make
better decisions about school and
advocate for curriculum and other things
so when we think about infants we think
about bedtime stories but you say it's
so much more than just reading books at
night absolutely so bedtime stories are
really important for building oral
language and vocabulary but with the
little ones we can also do a lot of
brain building through conversation so
it's really about that responsiveness
the back and forth exchange with little
ones
how often should parents be reading to
their kids because i'm thinking you know
you've got a new baby
you're just trying to get the kid to go
to sleep a lot of the time and stay
asleep i mean how often should you be
doing this reading establishing a daily
reading habit is wonderful but i like
people to think beyond bedtime because
that's not the best time for a lot of
families and also i want people to
recognize that particularly with the
infants it really is about those back
and forth exchanges and even treating
their coos and babbles as if they were a
conversation that's really responsible
absolutely so really thinking of it as a
dialogue from day one i really like that
part of it because for a lot of parents
like reading a book to their kid at
night they're the parents are out of
their mind tired they got another kid
who's screaming for something the
kitchen still needs to be cleaned it's
are you speaking from experience
absolute experience autobiographical
tony eloise does not get a bedtime story
and i struggle to get through teddy
bedtime stories right but what you're
saying is actually that for parents who
have those limitations as all parents do
they shouldn't beat themselves up the
the conversation can actually be a big
part of it absolutely the conversation
is critically important all those words
that you speak to a child all the things
that you're labeling and pointing to all
of that oral vocabulary is important for
them when they one day need to recognize
it in print it is important as they get
older let's say three four to start
bringing their attention to print so
dragging your finger across the page as
you're reading so they understand text
moves from left to right you forget that
little ones sometimes think we're
reading the pictures right they aren't
even tuned into the print but i also
like parents to know that you can take
advantage of print on cereal boxes or a
graphic t-shirt or a street sign
wherever there's print you can talk
about it that's super smart and tony
mentioned some of those things that
causes fatigue as a parent you're just
dealing with life so you're tired at the
end of the day what advice do you give
to parents that struggle to find time
parents definitely feel stressed and
fatigued and distracted so the key thing
is to remember that you're already
spending a ton of time with your child
and you can build these simple literacy
practices into everyday life meal times
diaper changing times these are all
opportunities to sing nursery rhymes and
again have those back and forth
conversations i i feel like you also
have to get other people involved like
i'm going to visit my new nephew this
weekend and i'm thinking okay aunt jamie
needs to maybe sit down and read a book
absolutely lean into your community
that's huge that's huge uh to what to
what extent is technology kind of the
reason for declines in literacy if there
are declines of literacy i don't think
that technology is necessarily a reason
for the decline in literacy but it does
distract us from doing some of the
things we need to do to build it so
parents on their own devices takes away
time from reading the stories and having
those and then they're not talking right
right yeah you're just scrolling exactly
so what are some of the biggest
takeaways from i think the biggest
takeaways are start early because
there's so much brain growth and
development that happens in those early
years with your child and again it makes
you a savvier more informed
knowledgeable parent as they approach
school age my opinion thank you so much
for joining us reading for our lives is
on sale now make sure you pick it up
start those conversations today you can
start it right now there's maya she's on
tv
thank you very much that's great